pop
m
[Musique]
e
vacances le voici arrivé le moment tant
attendu
on va partir on est partis départ
soigneusement méticuleusement organisé
départ aussi vouée à la plus haute
improvisation est au bout du chemin on
va enfin voir se profiler le coin
tranquille dont on a rêvé toute une
année les rayons du soleil sont
excellents pour l'organisme mais il faut
en user progressivement et avec mesure
n'essayez pas de faire disparaître trop
vite votre belle couleur aspirine
d'hommes blancs
les brûlures graves peuvent laisser des
cicatrices pour toute la vie une
exposition trop prolongée au soleil peut
entraîner des désordres sérieux dans
l'organisme
attention aussi aux surfaces surchauffée
houphouet de l'exercice vous bougerez
mais n'exagérez pas non plus ne forcez
pas comme disent les sportifs de trop
longues marches à pied ne sont pas la
formule à appliquer aux vacances
[Musique]
mordu de navigation sous marine ne jouez
pas au scaphandrier avec un matériel
insuffisant et il existe mille façons de
se faire remarquer sachez choisir
si vous campez ne vous croyez pas pour
autant obligé de démonter de remonter
votre tante tous les jours sous prétexte
de changer de coin le camping vous offre
c'est entendu une mobilité très grande
mais ne confondez pas camping et
mouvement perpétuel
vouloir évaluer ses vacances au nombre
de kilomètres parcourus au nombre
d'hôtels habité qui tu es là pour
s'installer dans l'autre mais pas non
plus une manière idéale de profiter de
ses vacances
d'autant que vous pourriez passer
certaines nuits dans des conditions de
confort plus que contestable
[Musique]
le sommet du mont-blanc 4807 m là n'ont
jamais réussi à se poser que des
hélicoptères c'est pourtant là que le
pilote henri giraud entend atterrir avec
son eee porter à 100 km/heure henri
giraud va se poser sur la petite piste
de 30 mètres il était venu balisé en
hélicoptère et ne s'arrêtera qu'à trois
mètres du précipice
en battant le record du monde
d'atterrissage en altitude c'est un
authentique exploit que vient de réussir
l'audacieux pilotes de l'aéro club
grenoblois est peu dire du décollage
[Applaudissements]
a dakar tandis que descendait du mât les
couleurs françaises un nouvel état est
née la fédération du mali réunion du
sénégal et du soudan au nom de la france
monsieur louis jacquinot ministre d'état
et monsieur modibo keïta au nom du
gouvernement fédéral dont il est le chef
ont échangé les instruments de
ratification des accords de transferts
de compétences
[Musique]
le soir-même l'assemblée fédérale
malienne consacré une séance
extraordinaire au vote de la loi
d'indépendance vote qui était obtenu à
l'unanimité
c'était ainsi un pays totalement
souverain qui allait par la suite en
signant les accords de coopération et de
participation à la communauté engagée
son avenir aux côtés de la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et lorsque son monter au mât les
couleurs du mali ont pu dire qu'une
nouvelle page des relations
franco-africaines venait d'être tournée
sans doute les fêtes de l'indépendance
ont elles été fixée officiellement au
mois de janvier
mais c'était oublier qu'ici on ne laisse
jamais passer un prétexte à danser
[Musique]
on
à l'aérodrome de tunis centre de
l'attention depuis le oui des
responsables du fln trois hommes m
boumendjel m magna ya 28 ans et enfin
leur secrétaire hakiki ben ammar telles
étaient les émissaires chargés d'établir
le contact avec paris et dont la mission
était précise préparer la venue de la
délégation fln missions essentiellement
technique dira m boumendjel
[Musique]
à orly des mesures avaient été prises et
l'axé du terrain interdit et les
journalistes ne purent qu'apercevoir
l'appareil s'est immobilisé en bout de
piste puis deux hélicoptères s'envoler
première manifestation du secret décidé
autour des pourparlers préliminaires
[Musique]
secret consentie de part et d'autre et
qui devait se prolonger tout autour de
la préfecture de melun dont les grilles
ne s'ouvraient que pour laisser passer
une voiture celle de monsieur roger
maurice représentant du gouvernement
français
[Musique]
longchamp à l'heure du grand prix de
paris élégante au pesage propriétaire
anthume gris et le général de gaulle
très détendue dans la tribune
présidentielle
[Applaudissements]
dans un instant le départ karim aga
quand on est un peu en retard peu
importe ce n'est pas lui qui va prendre
le départ mais le krach de son écurie
charleville le départ est donné et c'est
panurge qui prend la tête dans ces
conditions il n'est pas étonnant que le
peloton soit bien groupés derrière lui
ce qui est plus surprenant c'est que
certains concurrents aient l'intention
de doubler
[Musique]
et c'est ainsi que pinpoint s'est
échappée une rue d'émotion pour le
possesseur du billet de la loterie
nationale affectés à ce cheval c'est
peut-être déjà 150 millions dans son
escarcelle
ce n'était hélas qu'un rêve andy foulée
charlottesville a ramené tout le monde à
la réalité et riom aisément sans forcer
son talent en outre mesure
[Musique]
on comprend maintenant pourquoi karim
aga camp était souriant avant le départ
[Musique]
extraordinaire spectacle que celui de
ces jeunes filles qui exécutent des
figures d'ensemble à prague à l'occasion
des spartak cadel sont ainsi plus de
[Musique]
avouer qu'elles ont une curieuse manière
de jouer au cerceau il n'empêche que
tout cela est bien joli à regarder
on se demande comment ces gymnastes
parviennent à coordonner leurs
mouvements sans une fausse note
cela demande des mois de travail mais
aussi quelle récompense
[Musique]
les garçons eux n'ont que leur force
physique pour rivaliser avec les jeunes
filles il faut reconnaître qu'il ne s'en
tire pas si mal
m
non
mais c'est tout de même plus confus et
moins gracieux que l'exhibition des
jeunes filles anachronisme des 24 heures
du mans cette petite course désuète des
pilotes avant le départ des bolides qui
vont rouler bientôt à près de 300 à
l'heure dans les lignes droites
cette année les italiens sont venus en
force aux 24 heures du mans
pas moins de douze ferrari alors qu'il
n'y a que deux jaguar et deux aston
martin
de fait les ferrari vont rendre la
course monotone et presque dès le début
de l'épreuve la voiture numéro 11 des
belles gens de bien et paul frère va
prendre la tête pour ne plus la quitter
jusqu'à la fin des 24 heures cette
monotonie et même la pluie n'a pas
émoussé l'enthousiasmé des trois cent
mille spectateurs pieuse aussi pour la
plupart n'ont pas quitté le circuit du
début à la fin de la course
durant la nuit la db2 lorho et armagnac
fait merveille elle battre à tout le
monde à l' indice de performance
[Musique]
et
seuls les spectateurs au petit matin
s'accorde quelques moments de loisirs
pendant ce temps les voitures continuent
de rouler sans cesse où s'arrête pour
ravitailler
[Musique]
et finalement la ferrari numéro 11 de
gens de bien et paul frère va aisément
triomphé à 175 de moyenne madame ferrari
est la première à recevoir les
félicitations
[Musique]